welcome ken singleton
to throw out today's ceremonial first
pitch in honor of his retirement to his
good friend and fellow broadcaster
michael k
thank you again kenny
for all your years of broadcasting
yankees games and best of luck in your
retirement of course it had to come to
this the way this season has gone it had
to come to the last day and yankees have
to win jameson taiwan making his 29th
start of the year
pretty good record 8-6 4.4 row almost a
strikeout per inning and let's take a
look at our scout report on jameson he's
had a better second half this year but
one player he's going to watch out for
is meadows
tylen's made two starts against the rays
this year
austin meadows is homered in each in one
of those games against him and how far
can he go today well we'll see you know
he's got that ankle a tender ankle that
he's dealing with but uh if he's
effective the yankees are going to let
him go as far as he can and here is
nelson cruz and the pitches hit high in
the air to
left center there's gardner
and he makes the catch so tyonne gets
through the first inning the more
innings he pits
the fewer the bullpen has to pitch
starting pitchers presented by baycare
look what michael walker did his last
outing so efficient just 61 pitches no
hits no runs couple of base runners via
the walk six strikeouts so rizzo was on
and here is aaron judge ground ball
sharply hit short franco one to lau and
two to choy the end of one the raise and
the yankees are scoreless in new york
though tie on to the third left hand
hitting joey wendell strike three
one away looked like he lulled wendell
to sleep and then just tied him up with
this some cheese on the inner corner and
now taba has the first scoring
opportunity in the game they have first
and third and one man out here is a
rosarina a half swing did he go
eat it
so a rose arena is struck out and now
here's juan de franco and the pitch is
hit in the air to left field gently
gallow back to make the catch and ty
home pitches out of trouble terrific
pitching by tyo
took out tyonne to bring in the lefty
double in a walk two outs and joey
wendell who struck out looking his first
time hit on the ground a second diving
stop taurus from his knees goes to first
in time he just saved two runs the labor
torres that was a hard hit ball
headed to right field and torres made a
sliding grab and then from his knees
through to first
no runs one hit two left now here's
rizzo who is hit by a pitch there's a
swing and a little flare and a shallow
left meadows on the run dives and makes
the catch
gets back in and the throw to first not
in time
so rizzo had a base hit taken away and
got a little nervous as
meadows went into the dive because it
looked like he was going to roll over on
his hand
and that's how you
bust up hands and wrists
i didn't think it was going to catch you
just because it was too much ground to
cover that ball was dropping so fast and
what a terrific play by meadows he went
that glove down to the tips of the grass
and caught it while rolling over onto
the side there's nelson cruz two fly
balls for him one to center and one to
right
ground it and grab there by odor does it
360 and fires a strike to rizzo
that is not an easy hop you know you've
heard of sunday hops that was not one
that was a late saturday night hop when
you're
trying to navigate down the street
somewhere chad greene will take over and
deal
to austin meadows with two outs popped
up
gonna be a long run
oh what a play
and he goes into the dugout
can he hold on
yes he did oh what a play
i gotta see if he's okay michelle made
the unbelievable grab and his momentum
took him right down the steps into the
tampa dugout this guy has played with
his heart on his sleeve since he's
walked in the door here
and he's up
and he will walk slowly
to the yankee dugout and get a big hand
from the crowd what a play
in a huge moment international has taken
a 5-1 lead over the red sox jonathan
lawasika will come on with first and
second and two house to face brandon
loud swung on and popped him up off
third roogy near the stands rookie makes
the catch
gets it done no runs a hit no errors and
two men left on base in a scoreless game
on to the bottom of the seventh and
colin mchugh and boy what a big part of
this pitching staff he has been well
you're right and you know you've made
this point many times right here he's
given up three home runs in his 63
innings that's unbelievable but then you
go back and as you have pointed out
he gave up a home run on the first pitch
he threw as a ray yep slider lifted in
the air behind the mound
who's going to get it here comes troy
here comes wendell wendell says he does
and then choi runs into him and gave him
a forearm shiver
and hopefully wendell who went down on
the back of the mound is okay dave i saw
that coming together
i'm sure you did too the corner and
killers they were both calling for it at
the same time
and then choy reach up a little higher
and then he
he didn't even get him in the head so
much although mchugh held the made a a
face as if to say oh oh but uh for
wendell that's nothing right the
youngest of three boys he's been beat up
the lead ron the only run of the game is
at third with one man out and who's the
bad at nelson cruz swinging into miss
got him
sinking fastball in with a lot on it
look at peralta oh yeah
you demand two balls two strikes two
outs too much tension swung on a fly
ball to right judge is
and makes the catch
and the yankees get out of the eighth
inning georgetown red gardener gary
sanchez and the bottom of the eighth
against the former yankee robertson
ground ball up the middle that's franco
coming up with it and a nice play right
there
to get her shella and that's out number
one at the bottom of the eighth trying
to get that ball and squeeze it up the
middle just not able to it nice time
right there by wander franco on that
slide you got to let that ball get by
the leg
and so you're fielding it basically
behind you
and now you got to get up make the throw
david roberts said yes sir so wendell
walks and there's the go ahead run
manuel margot will come up a right-hand
hitter
well let's see if the yankees can get a
run and win the game the yankees now
have the winning run
at second and they have rizzo and they
have judge line drive it's a basic to
right field wave rounds third
and they hold them up
now going to second is rizzo as the
throw was wide
and the yankees have runners on second
and third and one out looks like they're
going to pitch to judge it does wade's
at third grizzo's at second bottom of
the ninth inning swung on and lined up
the middle and the throw home is not in
time
bowl game over yankees win
yankees
win and go to the playoffs
it was a hot shot up the middle that
actually tore
off pitrad's glove
racing it in to pick it up was loud he
threw home late
wade scores
and the yankees win
one nothing to go to the playoffs